Las mujeres me dijeron,
"Te adaptarás a este lugar.
Te acostumbrarás".
Ya no me llamaban Teresa Njoroge.
El número 415/11 era mi nueva identidad,
y pronto aprendí que ese era el caso de otras mujeres
con quién compartía ese espacio.
Y me adapté a la vida tras las rejas:
la comida de la prisión,
el idioma de la prisión,
la vida de la prisión.
La prisión ciertamente no es un mundo de cuento de hadas.
Lo que no comprendo es la manera
como mujeres y niños
con quien compartí tiempo y espacio,
habían sido encarceladas
por crímenes del sistema,
por una corrupción que requiere un culpable,
un chivo expiatorio,
para que la persona responsable
quede libre,
un sistema roto que rutinariamente vilipendia a los vulnerables,
a los más pobres de nosotros,
personas que no pueden pagar la fianza
o los sobornos.
Y así continuamos.
Mientras escuchaba historia tras historia
de estas casi 700 mujeres
durante ese año en prisión,
pronto me di cuenta de que el crimen
no fue lo que llevó a estas mujeres a prisión,
a la mayoría de ellas,
ni muchos menos.
Todo había comenzado con el sistema educativo,
cuyo suministro y calidad no es igual para todos;
la falta de oportunidades económicas
empuja a estas mujeres a crímenes de supervivencia menores;
el sistema de salud,
sistema de justicia social,
el sistema de justicia penal.
Si alguna de estas mujeres,
que eran en su mayoría de origen pobre,
caen por las grietas
del sistema en sí ya roto,
el fondo de ese abismo es una prisión,
punto.
Cuando completé mi sentencia de un año
en la prisión de mujeres de Langata,
tuve una convicción ardiente
de ser parte de la transformación
para resolver las injusticias
de las que yo había sido testigo
a mujeres y a niñas
que fueron atrapadas en una puerta giratoria
de una vida dentro y fuera de la prisión
debido a la pobreza.
Después de mi puesta en libertad,
puse en marcha Clean Start.
Clean Start es una empresa social
que busca dar a estas mujeres y niñas
una segunda oportunidad.
Tendemos puentes para ellas.
Entramos en las prisiones, las entrenamos,
les damos habilidades, herramientas y apoyo
para permitirles cambiar su forma de pensar,
sus comportamientos y sus actitudes.
También tendemos puentes hacia las cárceles
desde el sector corporativo.
Individuos, organizaciones
que se asocian con Clean Start
para permitirnos proporcionar empleo,
espacios a los que llamar hogar,
trabajos y entrenamiento vocacional
para estas mujeres, niñas,
niños y hombres,
desde la transición de vuelta a la sociedad.
Nunca pensé
que un día
estaría narrando historias
de las injusticias que son tan comunes
dentro del sistema de la justicia penal,
pero aquí estoy.
Cada vez que vuelvo a la prisión,
me siento un poco en casa,
pero es el trabajo desalentador
de lograr la visión
lo que me mantiene despierta por la noche,
lo que me conecta con Louisiana,
considerada la capital mundial del encarcelamiento,
llevando conmigo historias
de cientos de mujeres
a quienes he conocido dentro de las prisiones,
algunas de las cuales ahora tienen su segunda oportunidad,
y otras que todavía están en el camino del transcurso de la vida.
Yo encarno una frase
de la gran Maya Angelou.
"Vengo sola,
pero soy como 10 000".
(Aplausos)
Porque mi historia es singular,
pero imaginen junto a mí
los millones de personas
en las cárceles de hoy,
que anhelan libertad.
Tres años después de mi condena
y dos años tras mi puesta en libertad,
los tribunales de apelación me dejaron
libre de cualquier cargo.
(Aplausos)
Casi al mismo tiempo,
fui bendecida con mi hijo,
a quien llamé Uhuru,
que en mi dialecto significa "libertad".
(Aplausos)
Porque finalmente había obtenido la libertad
que tanto anhelaba.
Vengo sola,
pero soy como 10 000
alentada por la dura esperanza
de que miles de nosotras nos hemos reunido
para reformar y transformar el sistema de justicia penal,
alentadas por hacer nuestro trabajo
como estamos destinadas a hacerlo.
Y sigamos haciéndolo
sin pedir disculpas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)